[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening my friends and welcome to
piers morgan uncensored with me jeremy
carr now the big man still away on his
summer break but we'll do our best to
bring you the usual fistful of big
interviews and feisty debates and to
tell you the truth i'm rather getting
used to filling in for morgan i've
started arguing with myself in the
mirror when i get out of the shower i
had a nightmare about meghan markle last
night certain cabinet ministers have
started crossing the road in terror to
avoid me and most notably my friends
i've broken the habit of a lifetime
today i've started twittering whatever
that means look at this there i am at j
kyle official like an intercity express
you'll find me on all platforms but i
will arrive on time and i'm self-driven
uh matin hats on so use me and abuse me
more of the former if you don't mind but
importantly i really would love to hear
from you because all of this week we're
bringing you analysis and expert
insights on britain's summer of strife
the cost of living crisis we'll talk
food we'll talk energy prices transport
and much much more and we want to know
how you're coping and actually not so
please do not be shy
right first tonight the cost of living
crisis and what to do about it new data
today from the post office reveals that
as the summer heats up more and more
people are going back to cold hard cash
the post office handled more than 800
million quid in personal cash
withdrawals in july the most since
records began and a spike of 20 on last
year thought to be due quite literally
to people counting the pennies and
helping themselves to budget surely just
another sign of a creeping crisis that
is engulfing every single one of us
today we're going to talk about the
surging price of food and joining me now
a restauranteur and celebrity chef
anthony warrell thompson and financial
expert gemma godfrey guys welcome we
were talking there in the introduction
start with you anthony it's not getting
any easier is it no no it's not i mean
everywhere you go i mean i've got
restaurants i mean the prices have gone
absolutely skyrocketing i mean it's not
just the fuel
to just take a
a 20 litre
tub of oil 1799 to 42.99
unbelievable lamb that upper third beef
up more than a third and that's going to
be reflected in the supermarket as well
you know they do try and keep their
prices down but they're being charged in
prices
so as a restaurant uh your prices are
going up and and you know that's because
your suppliers prices are going
absolutely and and what is it what is it
telling you what what about business are
less and less people uh eating out i
mean i was in a restaurant on saturday
night right with my kids and it was
ridiculous it took hours it took two
hours and the guy said to me jess
there's no staff yeah there's no
suppliers we're really really struggling
it is tough i think
we're lucky i think we've become a
destination restaurant so people are
going out for anniversaries birthdays
that sort of thing so i think what's cut
back is the everyday eating where people
would maybe eat out two or three times a
week as a matter of course and i think
now it's going to move much more to
celebrity stuff where you you're really
enjoying the occasion it's a special
occasion you know and
food prices
i mean it's going to be a lot of
restaurants for our point of view who go
down the tubes you know what about
people who wouldn't be able to afford to
go to a restaurant we're talking about
everyday food stuff we're talking about
prices going through the roof in all
levels of supermarkets we've talked
about ukraine and grain but what is co
we talked about a host pipe bound the
other day and crops dying and and that
what is essentially causing this and
what hope can we give i think a lot of
people are jumping on the bandwagon
personally um i mean you know logistics
have gone up you know transport's gone
big time staff wages have gone up a lot
more than they say they have in the
press from my point of view and i think
it's the obviously
you know utilities massive um
people aren't they're not dropping their
rents uh
it's just and also the ukraine obviously
is putting a huge i've got i've got one
question you know when prices go up and
suppliers and restauranters and
supermarkets increase their prices and i
mean this respectfully
when it balances itself out and price is
right it price is lower then do
supermarkets and restaurants show the
reduction as quickly as they show the
increase i've got a nasty feeling they
won't um
you know when they they dropped the v80
in restaurants you didn't notice many
price drops in the restaurants you know
when people who dropped the v80
um
it's going to be a tough one um i mean
you know just as a vicious example i
mean our you'd say this is we used to
pay 12 grand now we're paying 37 to 40
grand that's ridiculous gemma godfrey's
going to join me every day this week
financial expert and actually we were
talking last week and you said i i try
and give people tips and in the past
maybe people would have thought what's
the point but it's becoming real and you
know people will say to me oh why are
you peddling this because it's true
right it is it's absolutely critical i
mean we're going to see in the winter
time we're going to see families trying
to choose between feeding their families
and staying warm and when you're looking
at those edges it means that these small
changes can make a difference and there
are lots of people that are struggling
but there are things that people could
do i mean there's a website there's a
government website where they've got um
it's called help for households and
they've actually put a lot of the deals
there so for example you've got all the
deals with the supermarkets they're
making you know feed your family for a
fiver those types of deals so that's a
good place to start okay let's not get
stung there's also be aware of don't go
to convenience stores because you pay
for the convenience but also then don't
travel too far where you're paying too
much in petrol and then be careful of
loyalty programs compare them and i
think the last one is we talk about
prices increasing what we're not talking
about is sizes shrinking is that for the
same thing you're going you're going out
and you're not getting as much as you
used to 16 million households will fall
into food poverty let's just leave that
out there that's just crazy and i don't
you know listen we can be as political
or non-political as we want is it time
for the government lots of stuff today
you know johnson's on holiday the
government's paralyzed we're waiting for
this leadership debate i'll nail my
colors i think it's ludicrous but boris
johnson can't win can he because they
told him not to do anything fiscally
because he's not the prime minister and
if he did get involved but should we not
be doing something should there not be
some sort of help right now from the
government yeah there should be some
form of support because what we're
hearing now is about tax cuts they all
come later on what people actually need
is people are living hand to mouth and i
think one area where we could have an
improvement is around waste i mean we
tend to waste about a quarter of our
food well i was going to i wouldn't say
this to you anthony because everybody
goes on about food wastage there is
always going to be food wastage how can
we not recycle the wrong word how can we
not i think we're making that more
available to the people that need it
well yeah i mean that that's one thing
but the key is also shopping when you
need it not thinking oh i might need it
you know don't do the big shop anymore
am i okay it's going to use a little bit
more petrol maybe but buy things as you
need them fresh things there's also
another idea what you could do is if you
take your weekly food shop you take your
receipt you put it on your fridge and
then every time at the end of the week
you've actually thrown something away
you cross it off and then you end up
with a list of just the items you need
can i say something that that would come
from my mum god rush to sell but but
this probably wouldn't be popular with
everybody is it time that
there is a crisis i actually accept that
but should not more families be advised
helped shown to go back to basics are we
not also if we're honest a society that
is
using convenience foods and
not doing what they did in the old days
without wanting to sound ancient i
personally think they should tax unless
what i call unnecessary food so all
processed foods all foods that are ready
meals and and
make people have to pay if they want
convenience like that they want to be
lazy they don't want to cook
tax them on that and i think but the
essentials in life we should draw up a
list of what's essential and
ideally we should do deals with
supermarkets as those prices can come
down i mean supermarkets have been
getting rid of a lot of their sort of
value ranges which is wrong and they
should be bringing those back and trying
to help the impoverished families you
know you you were going to say something
well i think the only challenge is hard
work there are lots of you know single
parent families hard working families
that have been pushed down to using
convenient food and it isn't as healthy
and they're getting into that rut so i
think there are a lot of families out
there that don't know where to turn
they've been told to do ready meals now
they're not healthy now those prices are
going up and we heard today um a certain
supermarket's brought out a value range
and because they colored it yellow and
yellow is known for reduced they're
getting a lot of backlash that people
are now embarrassed to use it rather
than yeah rather than it being promoted
as a way to save money this is going to
this is going to affect everybody
students care homes you know uh
all sorts of people and and as i say we
we do this we're going to do this cost
of living crisis every single week we
pajama every night this week and we're
going to look at different parts but
food we have the the chairman of the the
president of the nfu on friday and he
was saying you know that this drought
this lack of water the crops are dying
they're more expensive i mean it is
possible in this country to to wake up
every day and think what the hell is
next yeah i mean if you think about i
love using the example of milk right you
get an increased price of gas because
obviously energy prices are going up
that means that fertilizer is getting
more expensive it's getting more
expensive to feed castle then you have
the labor then you have the machinery in
every aspect food is getting more
expensive and as we said we're going
towards the winter when people are going
to be spending more on energy so we all
agree there's a problem and we all think
that the government needs to do
something certainly needs to be a bit
more visible but people are going to
have to which again going back to the
older generation they're gonna say you
know you're gonna have to get your head
down and do something about this what
can we say what can people just a few
things what can people do to make that
that budget stretch to make that food
shop easier batch cooking for me i mean
start i mean okay not everyone's gonna
afford a freezer but if you could make
stuff in bulk yep doesn't take any
longer to cook than a small portion so
you can batch it up and bag it up and
tub it up and freeze it put a date on it
know when you've frozen it i think the
supermarket's gonna help by having less
packaging so someone could pick up a
couple of tomatoes instead of a whole
carton of tomatoes what about a cut of
meat help me out i want to make a batch
people watching this what's a good cheap
cut of meat that's good
we would use something like god and
sticking which is a good stewing stuff
you get the babettes um
topside is a boring old prisma it's used
for roasting this country but it's
actually very dry but something good
mint you know used mint it is so cheap
and i think use the time of the
supermarkets when
prices are going to be down end of the
evening first thing in the morning
you've got to shop around and
don't buy unnecessary goods and go with
a shopping list because people
impulse buy and that's why cash is
coming in because people don't want to
run up a credit card because they're
tempted to that gemma final word from
you i just think that the more people
shop around the better deals obviously
you can get and the more you're
encouraging supermarkets to then remain
competitive as well but honestly we need
more help with food banks there are so
many families out there that are really
struggling well we're going to talk
about food banks later in the week you
know people would assume that they're
open all the time they're not people
would assume that they're heavily you
know supported they're not there's all
sorts of thank you both very much
next on uncensored rail fails and pumped
up petrol prices are causing misery for
millions we'll ask what's fueling
britain's transport crisis and more
importantly how can we fix it
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a road riddle how do you get to use the
highways with no license no insurance
without paying any tax and with
absolutely no speed limit the answer is
of course as easy as riding a bike
that's mibelle i promise you one thing
this is the only time ever you'll see me
doing this i get irrationally angry
about cyclists i mean it we wrote this
don't come near me i'm a psychopath
but seriously nice what's not to loathe
there's the toy hoys they dress up like
the tour de france from 15 minute pedal
to work he got the chain gangs usually
four of them riding side by side like
some massive peloton was as tax-paying
motorists queue behind getting later and
later and more irate you've got the
sigourney weavers uh through the miss
were they like a shopping trolley with a
dodgy wheel and you're jeremy vines
whoever he is with more cameras than
kodak picking fights and running red
lights it's good news though it turns
out i'm not the only one who thinks
these two tired tyrants are run out of
road today the government announced
thank god it might just force cyclists
to buy insurance follow speed limits pay
fines for ignoring the laws of our road
so at last says me with one hand off the
wheel a common sense reform bringing
cycling into the 21st century
almost everyone's had plans derailed by
the biggest train walkouts in 30 years
that mick lynch has ideas above his
station doesn't he more strikes than a
10-pin bowler the three more are planned
this month and you can forget about
london underground they work less days
than santa claus but my friends at least
there's one faithful engine we can
always rely on
that's right thomas the tank engine that
faithful symbol of british railroad
reliability and service with a smile but
sadly no more
thomas has tanked i took my kid to see
him today there we are lovely sadly we
discovered on arrival that thomas
couldn't perform properly because it was
too hot apparently sparks from his
engine could cause fires in the hot
weather so he could only move 100 meters
in and out of the station so there you
have it my friends even thomas has
packed it in now there is of course a
serious side to this so let's get back
on track before i run out of steam and
lose my train of thought cost of living
it's not just public transport facing
crisis for many people the cost of fuel
is becoming a very serious problem
record prices mean just getting to work
for many is becoming too expensive the
cost of oil and gas made worse by the
war in ukraine is driving up prices and
squeezing supply so much so but today we
learned this is just extraordinary the
uk is now expecting planned power cuts
this winter
great
hold on hold on hold on hold on if we go
down excuse me
hello
rob i need some money for the meter mate
we haven't got any cash left brilliant
we've got no cash bingo thank you very
much did you like that oh that was good
right first tonight uh those painful
prices at the pumps fuel costs have
finally started to fall but they're
still near record highs the rac today
says the gap between four court prices
and wholesale prices is the widest in
almost a decade at the start of the week
the average petrol price at britain's
biggest four supermarkets was 174 litre
diesel at 186. now we did some research
the cheapest place to fill up is here
dale head garage in [ __ ] in north
yorkshire great for the good people of
[ __ ] but it's 250 miles away from this
studio so my little fiat 500 in brackets
trying to sound like rishi soon at close
brackets that's close to 100 squid round
trip just to get there
i wrote this so if you can't pop into
[ __ ] what can you do joining me now
thank you uh a financial expert gemma
godfrey here every night former a top
gear presenter a motoring legend steve
berry and my good old mate howard cox
from the campaign group fair fuel uk i'm
going to start with you howard um a lot
of people will talk about the difference
between the four court price
and what it costs you know the supplier
or whatever you're calling for a fuel
duty cut of 25 p per liter
quick question can we afford that
absolutely in the last year this
government is wallowing in an extra 4
billion of vat because of the high
prices and don't forget the vit is on
the duty as well it's a double taxation
and fundamentally as you mentioned
earlier the wholesale price let's get
this right june the first for example
was uh 30p oh it's now 30p less than it
was in june the first why
and yet the retail price has gone up 4p
what what why what
help me out
why aren't supermarkets lowering their
prices more
to almost save the motoring industry
because we are hearing real stories of
people who might not be able to get
their kids to school people who might
not be able to get to work i mean i say
it and i've said it with gemma every
night this week you wake up in this
country and you think what is next
people cannot afford petrol why is
something not being done but we're
talking about it and a lot of other
people are starting to talk about it i
think people nearly said something i
shouldn't i think people are getting
angry genuinely angry about this and i
think that's why we're having this
conversation and it's happening in homes
and workplaces and businesses and in
pubs all over the country people are
starting to ask that question why isn't
it lower why isn't the price been
lowered
and i think they're gonna have to react
and it's gonna some are reacting and
because the others have
they charge what they think they can get
but here's the interesting thing with
that research of the garage in great
halls is people are queuing down the
road to go to that garage so does that
in a business way say to you that if
garages take the decision to be
competitive they will do better but i
don't understand again we're going to
bring it gemma back to the government
you know i watched these
two people vying to get to number 10
promising this promising that but yet
again nobody from the government front
and center saying we know you're
struggling in another way in polio today
that's something else but but but why
howard to me it makes so much sense to
cut that and reduce some pain for people
well we've got to ask is one is to cut
fuel duty germany have done it by 25b
france has done it by 20p uh spain have
done it by 20 billion ireland 17p we did
it by 5p in march at the spring
statement and it didn't touch the sides
you didn't see it but i remember that it
was two quid a liter and he said all
this massive thing you take 5p off and i
remember that exact day gemma right
because and i think we talked on the
radio it was 195. it came down to 190 by
the time i parked the car about 100
yards down the road that one had gone to
two quid it's not fair is it it's not
fair what we're seeing is prices they're
increasing prices very quickly so it's
not the case that actually all changes
take a lot a lot of time to implement
very quick to increase prices but they
haven't decreased the prices as much
they should do and it's real people
people are playing now it's a postcode
lottery of where you live to be able to
get cheaper petrol tips
well okay so in terms of tips again
we've seen such a huge increase in
petrol prices that you know everybody is
struggling but it's the simple things
like um i mean you're not going to like
this one but you know don't accelerate
so hard uh empty your why is he not
gonna like that well you know if you
like driving fast you know accelerating
hard is going to increase your fuel
consumption um an extra 25 kilograms in
your boot is going to increase your fuel
consumption by a percentage in this hot
weather or here's a tough one if you put
on air conditioning that will also
increase your fuel consumption but if
you decrease it and open your windows
that can increase the drag here's morgan
text earlier could i ask when you talk
about turning down the ac what about his
new car with the cold seats and the hot
and cold thing for his coffee what's he
supposed to do about that very very
tough and if he's if he's got the roof
down as well that could create a drag as
well yeah horrible must be difficult in
la moving on um
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyway moving on uh steve the motoring
industry is there more that the motoring
industry can do not really it's too
short-term this is this has happened
very recently hasn't it and these are
the dying days of the dead tree juice i
mean the electric future is going to
happen before we know it there is one
advantage to this uh panic over uh fuel
prices though you can buy some very
tasty mortars very cheap play if you
apolo mine just bought a porsche cayenne
s with a full service history about 11
years old very nice order
2 000 of your english pounds i was again
i got offered a mercedes coupe the other
day five liter v8 so when you say that
to people now they're like oh my god the
only thing that won't pass is a petrol
station
the cow is a thousand pounds
nobody wants those big old barges so if
you ever lusted after one now is that
electric motors
look how much the cars cost in the first
place
yes you're saving money on by plugging
it in and people are very smug about all
that and they think they're saving the
planet
but the initial purchase price is so
high
cradle to grave
if you compare crowded grave for an
electric vehicle with internal
combustion engine there's hardly any
difference in terms of saving the planet
in terms of co2 emissions do you know
what the more the greenest vehicle and
they were green so there's a clue that
was ever made was because of cradle to
grave
the world war ii jeep yeah because it's
how long they keep going for and people
one of the things that morris can do is
not chop and change the car so much
you know i mean the old days of thinking
oh it's going to be all worn out a
hundred thousand miles
a good you know we'll drive it into the
ground
just keep it insulate until it falls and
then if you've got a big motor these
days you're getting 500 quid for scrap
for a bigger howard um fearful uk
campaign has done such a lot of good you
always tell me that the politicians are
listening you know we've heard then
france has done it germany's done it
what do we need
do the companies need pressure bought on
them by political leaders because
there's no government in sight that's
what i mean that's why i said to you at
the beginning i would have thought that
one of those two leadership candidates
would have thought oh this is a really
good opportunity maybe they will i don't
know are you getting through to the
politicians with your message today well
i've met with both of them individually
have you in the long run it's going to
win three weeks uh liz is going to win
with these
and simply this the reason is the tax
cutting issue is the big one of course
but i'm afraid that rishi is actually it
was found by bloomberg who actually
published that he wants to put a green
taxes on diesel and petrol we're already
paying the highest tax is in the world
we're already paying the highest petrol
in the world and this here's the thing
uh jeremy it's very important to
understand our second ask is for we
we've got off gem offcom off what why
haven't we got something for pump watch
there are 37 million drivers in this
country and they don't have any uh price
protection whatsoever do you believe
them both well liz will win we all know
that do you believe her when she says
she'll get a grip of this yes or no
i think i think yes she will i i'm more
convinced i i was a fan of penny morton
i that's who i was going for because she
immediately came out and said she's
going to cut field duty obviously that's
my campaign i worry i worry about you
know the promises that they make i'm
going to throw something out watch that
what's that watch steve barry's face um
i don't upset uh cyclists
but i have absolutely no idea why
cyclists who seem to dominate our roads
nowadays and don't have to pay anything
in petrol don't have to pay road tax
themselves or get insured one has to
move about five feet out the way you get
abused they take pictures of you why
aren't they taking some responsibility
well what do you want me to say do you
agree
with every single syllable you just and
they shave their legs to go faster which
does my head in but it's true isn't it
cyclists that do you know they should be
taxed yes i should absolutely and they
should have their an mot on their
motorbike
and they should have some sort of
identification but don't say you can't
do it because they already do it in
denmark you're paying for petrol you've
got everything you want on the roads and
you don't pay any money jim what no i i
also think that they're doing what they
need to for their health as well they're
getting out they're doing exercise i
don't know i think that we want to
encourage people to be doing more
because i think during the pandemic
i get that i get that but should they
not shoulder some of the burden because
motorists are shouldering a reason can
you please use the cycle lanes that
would be nice okay okay are you a
cyclist i'm not a cyclist i just feel
like you know what yeah well there's a
place for people there is a place but
they're taking over our roads and
there's
yeah
so you hope this message this this this
cut that you want um in in fuel duty of
25 p you're hopeful that liz trust will
listen you're hopeful that the next
prime minister we believe it will be her
will do this because if it doesn't
happen very briefly from all three of
you what happens well we're in dire
straits it's impacting on the economy as
you've made the point people are really
suffering people can't even afford to
fill their car to go to medical points
to hospitals there's that issue that's
happening they're not going to the
supermarket once a week they're going
once a month now so it's impacting on
the high street the whole thing is
costing a problem i'm uh backed by the
road haulage association something like
50 of the truckers costs is fuel
unbelievable steve briefly
the economy's got to get back from the
from the pandemic people have got to get
back to work if they can't afford to
drive to the place that they do their
work how are we going to do that
brilliant guys thank you so much next on
uncensored inflation hits 10 this for
the first time in 40 years and food
prices are surging the big question how
are we going to be punishing prices of
the tills we're coming right back don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
uh welcome back to uncensored my friends
so apparently sad news it's the
beginning of the end removal fans are at
10 downing street boris is getting the
exit done he's taking back control of
carrie's golden wallpaper and fittingly
in a financial emergency today's report
suggests that the pm will serve the
remainder of his premiership at the
chequers mansion in buckinghamshire
sauce says he wants to keep calm and
carry on doing absolutely nothing of
course that's all speculation the
removal vans may well simply be packing
for his next holiday or perhaps they've
just been to the cash machine in mayfair
before doing the weekly shop because
based on today's inflation figures
that's where we're heading my friends
rocketing food prices have pushed
inflation above 10
for the first time since 1982.
prices i have to be honest are now
higher than keith richards on new year's
eve and this is what it means for
shoppers chills at the tills
consoling in the isles it's murder on
the tescos express now we've done a
survey of the uk's biggest supermarkets
and found that a year ago look at this
this is a medium white loaf of bread
this is very good it comes from the kyle
supermarket which by the way is actually
quite slow because we can't afford the
electricity anyway it was one pound and
five now oh it's there now it's one
pound 20 which is an increase of 15 and
it goes on hopefully a bit quicker a tin
of beans right a fixture on everybody's
cupboard was 85 p
very quick it's not here yet see come on
wind it up there it is see now one pound
21 that's a massive 42 percent increase
they'll have gone up another 10 by the
time these graphics are finished i
should imagine six eggs different colors
probably one smashed uh they used to be
uh 172 moving quickly here they are
unfertilized but now they've gone up 15
nearly 2 quid at 197.
moving back pack of bacon it's going
well isn't it two pounds and threatens
that's what my old girl used to say and
over here in about a minute come on then
why oh there's the bacon uh we see it's
now two pounds 68 that is up 32
these by the way of course are some of
the ingredients for the once humble full
english breakfast an ordinary morning
staple for thousands of working people
but at this rate they'll probably only
be serving you at the dorchester and
checkers in a moment our experts will
have their say on what the hell we're
going to do about it but first and this
is important we got out on the streets
because we wanted to know what you
thought have a look at this
we know children with the cost of living
who they don't they evidently come to
school having not been fed but they
don't want to say it they don't want to
mention it at all the cost of living is
going on by inflation oh god inflation
is like can i swear i can't swear right
okay cool because they're gonna go so
so high so quickly but at the moment
it's mostly uh like travel and stuff is
like really bad um but also
i'm just about to move into a house so
i'm like really concerned about what my
bill is going to kind of start out as
joining me now is our financial expert
gemma godfrey the former founder and
managing director of the 99p store
hussein lulani i'm gemma welcome hussain
welcome um
we've been talking about this for two
weeks now inflation the highest for 40
years at 10
and just an attempt by us to explain how
staple food staple food
is almost for many people impossible and
i know we say every night but we have to
say everything what are people supposed
to do jim and also well the biggest
problem with this is that we talk about
staple food staple food is a bigger
percentage of people's weekly budget and
when they're worst off that means that
for the worst off they're actually not
seeing 10 inflation but it could be
about double so people are really
struggling and they're spending more on
credit cards but in terms of what they
could do obviously it's a very very
tough time and honestly many families
are really struggling um but there's for
example there's you know help for
households so there's feed your family
for a fiver at sainsbury's one pound
children's meal at asda there's um you
get free children's meals um in the cafe
of morrison so that's really good a lot
of supermarkets are trying to do what
they can but one of the most i think
savvy things people can do is also um
change the time in which they shop so
yes because um you know yellow sticker
sticker items you know a lot of the
supermarkets start to discount their
food and they do it at certain times of
the day well that's good because there's
so much food that's wasted right
absolutely and not only that but there
was a family it was again reported
across the press that they got 85 pounds
worth of food for 14 pounds a few years
ago and so it means that again the three
times to watch out for are either
they'll um put those yellow sticker
items for one's approaching best before
dates overnight to go first thing in the
morning or it'll happen just after the
lunchtime rush or an hour just before
closing and the key thing there is to
try and pick freezable food because it
is approaching it's best before dave if
you can freeze it it'll last for longer
amazing as ever hussein um the 99p store
was the business you set up you sold it
to poundland in 2015. i i wouldn't i
think be unfair to say that seven or
eight years ago people would go
poundland many people right the reality
is that these stores now are now
providing staple things for people
because of what's going on how bad is it
out there it's bad and we saw this we
saw inflation creeping up when we sold
our stores but what's happened in the
last six months is unprecedented you
know poundland stopped selling products
for a pound five or six years ago after
their quite us it's really pound plus
you you only find a handful of products
for a pound in a pound store and you
know in food inflation is one one key
problem but you can't ignore energy
costs going up well i've actually got
some breaking news which is really
interesting and it caused you to look at
me weirdly off gem director christine
farnish has quit tonight over the energy
price cap what does that mean why
because she can't handle well the
biggest the biggest um uh pushback
people have had is what's an energy
price cap when it's not capping anything
yeah and also there's a target it's not
a cap exactly and also the problem is is
that they used to adjust it if it was
going to be adjusted at all once every
six months and they recently came out
and said they're going to be adjusting
it every three months obviously to allow
it to fall but really it's to allow it
to rise much more quickly as well so
she's not the big criticism was that the
off gem didn't do enough to protect
consumers and during that time obviously
energy companies have benefited
unbelievable um hussein um
how do we get out of this for people
watching who watch and go yes but we
know about that
inflation up
food prices through the roof petrol
diesel electricity gas
so what we've got to do is we've got to
focus on the most vulnerable in society
quite right average you know the average
household income is about 30 000 pounds
and you know they will weather the storm
they'll have to cut back the middle
class will maybe not go out for the
fancy meal not get a new sofa a new tv
but the most vulnerable in society the
poorest in society those on benefits
those on universal credit because as you
so rightly said food and energy makes up
a bigger proportion of the small amount
of money they get and that's what we've
got to focus on so one great idea i've
heard recently is to have social pricing
for energy for those most vulnerable in
our society having a special tariff just
can i can i do something that i do all
the time and i do it without apologizing
i absolutely know what you're saying
about people on benefits and people on
universal credit but i talk about jams
every single night in the show they're
just about managing because people who
are not on benefits and do not get
universal credit and both the couple's
partners work and they pay all their
bills and they have jack left and those
people could do with help as well
because they are right on the line but
you're right why can't they're right on
the line and the danger is that they
will fall over over the line and all of
a sudden they won't be able to keep up
with their mortgage payments and then
you know we've got issues of
homelessness more people losing their
homes um interest rates are going up
that's another
factor that's now affecting every
household budget and you know the scary
thing is this this is a cascade because
the family stops going out for meals so
the shop the restaurant now suffers the
workers in the restaurants get laid off
more unemployment and you know people
stop going out shopping to buy luxury
items buying a new suit or a pair of
trousers again retailer stuff where the
employees suffer the whole logistics
chain nobody you're a businessman i'm
not right but both of you
cascade's a great word it's like the dam
has been broken and everything is
falling about our our feet did nobody
see this coming i mean it had people go
boris but i mean i've heard about
ukraine i've heard about the pandemic
i've heard but
the monumental scale of how people's
lives are going to be impacted as has i
think shocked everybody the government
as well or not well the thing is is as
soon as you had the russia ukraine
conflict that was inevitably on day one
that was going to affect the oil price
if that's gonna affect the oil price
it's gonna affect energy bills and it's
gonna affect everything what's really
interesting is there is a bit of light
at the end of the tunnel in terms of the
wholesale price of flour
of wheat and also of oil has actually
come down recently but not but it'll
take about six months for that for that
to filter through to supermarkets and in
those six months if we're having such a
damaging effect on consumers and not
going out and buying as much businesses
then suffer more jobs are lost and by
the time that actually filters through
the economy has already been damaged and
then we're talking about winter as well
and yeah exacerbating every problem it's
terrifying for so many families you know
i used to be on on the board of age uk
and we look after the elders in our in
our society they're terrified you know
they can't they can barely afford
electricity and heat anyway and they've
got winter approaching and right now
there's no help what is a hundred pounds
energy credit going to do for them you
know the advice they're getting now is
get some more blankets that's why that's
why i got so upset about that story with
roy muller who's worked all of his life
and paid his taxes in his house in
birmingham being you know
just dealing with jobs you know
threatening him each and every day and
wants to leave a house he's been in for
44 years can we both of you is there
anything you can say to give people hope
because i don't want to sit here and say
you know sugar coated it's not great but
you've been really constructive over the
last two weeks what can you say jim well
i think one of the big stark stats i saw
recently is the fact that people are now
using their credit cards to buy
essential goods it's not for luxury
items anymore it's for essential goods
which means that people are more likely
to be falling into debt and obviously
that gets more and more expensive so
things like becoming a little bit more
savvy about where you shop be aware of
convenience stores try to go to larger
stores
and look at loyalty programs but also
try and compare them you know all these
little small things look it's tiny
things but at times like this it really
is about surviving not thriving it's
about trying to survive this period um
to be able to get through the winter
um just sum it up for me what would you
say to people watching this tonight i
would say what's your pennies you know
when when i had my stores you know it
was a 99 peace store and we said watch
that you know we give you a penny change
but today more than ever that penny
change really does count and you're
right you know trade down go to
different stores shop around buy frozen
products because they last longer less
likely to spoil and you know just
tighten your belts and you know let's
just hold tight and try to weather the
storm but it won't last forever you know
and that's the message and it won't you
know it won't last forever eventually we
will get out of this war with you you
know russia will withdraw from ukraine
and that will get the balance rise uh
really good thank you love it gemma
godfrey uh hussein lelani foreign pistol
next uncensored students receive their
a-level results this week but do you
need to go to university to be a success
we'll discuss that after this break
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends now settle down
settle down stop talking about you lot i
might be the substitute teacher well
that nasty mr morgan's away but you
don't intimidate me thank you very much
of course a-level results and
celebrations for many today
commiserations for some and for those
licking their wounds tonight here's the
thought that will balance your minds
prince harry got one b and a d and he
retired at 30 which proves that
anything's possible if you believe in
yourself and your nan just so happens to
be the queen now the best grades of a
and a star were down look at this we're
doing it again eight point look at the
money that spent eight point four
percent on last year which sounds like
bad news but remember this is the first
year since the pandemic that students
sat real exams those top grades are
actually up 11
on pre pandemic levels and despite
fierce competition today 425 830
students have secured a place at a unit
uk university which is a brand new
record now one of those lucky people is
my daughter alice she got straight a's
she's off to the university of her
choice i can't mention which one because
nobody will talk to her but al so proud
and so happy that you've managed to
achieve your dreams we're joined now god
uh we're joined now by head teacher
serge can you say your sir namely so far
i'm only joking a financial expert gemma
godfrey and sam prince maiden chelsea
star and business owner who actually
left school at 16 that has a very
interesting story to tell not a lot of
time serge let's start with you i'm
probably a bit old-fashioned and i want
to point out straight away i went to
university did a meaningless call course
had three years of having a great time
and probably would have done what i did
if i didn't do it are we now at a point
where going to university is not as
important relevant and guaranteed to
give you a job as it was in the past
depends depends what you want to go to
university for yeah for me uh i think
for certain professions it's absolutely
essential but for others
no and uh
i think we lack alternatives for kids
with fantastic talents that i know i
always down the academic route with
lovely kids who maybe if we brought in
apprenticeships etc you know early on
target these kids something that can be
proud of that are credible that's a far
better way to go for an awful lot of
kids without them leaving university
which as you said a meaningless course
uh with huge debt and perhaps not as
employable as they were three years
before two things to you sam because i
know you probably think like i think i'm
not being disrespectful i think there's
too many courses in too many colleges i
think kids end up in huge amounts of
debt and it is not a byword to get a job
anymore that is not saying that lots of
people who get degrees don't succeed but
does it mean as much as it did in the
past
i don't think you know i think
university is
it's not essential i think life is um
life is of course itself i think people
push down the union group when i didn't
do the uni room and i think um i've
learned so much of not doing that it's
interesting um you left school at 16.
you said yes your your family had money
but your dad was was very strict and you
still should now gave you a grand and
you made it on your own and that's a
great story and you proved by working
your backside off that you could make
something of your life yeah and i think
it's a life less than the fact if he
gave me everything which at that time i
wanted everything yeah the fact he gave
me a hard time at a young age it's
allowed me to really work hard and
establish what my passion dreams really
are um gemma um we're actually at
loggerheads tonight on this you think i
mean i i just i i sound like a hypocrite
but it's not a byword to a job anymore
and you end up in debt no no i agree i
mean i think i definitely think there is
value in certain degrees i think it's a
challenge because there are certain
degrees that aren't applicable there are
other degrees that are of course if you
have an apprenticeship which i'm a big
fan of it means that you don't go into
debt you can get paid you can get a job
at the end of it but i think there are
ways in which you can do research to
find out which degrees are actually in
demand and also there are some companies
that are working in collaboration with
universities telling them the skills
they need and we'll give them a year in
industry and i think things like that
are getting much more pragmatic i think
going forward um
who was it who said net was it you sam
who said your your network
is your net worth agreed what do you
mean by that i think uh i was i think
meeting the right people is great i
think putting yourself in the right
rooms and shaking has meant one thing
growing up is that i want to shake as
many hands as possible okay take this
the right way because we're we'll be
friends after this isn't it easy if you
come from a better background to have
that network to succeed than if you
don't what if you're brought up in
poverty what if you know university is
the aspiration because frankly that
might be the only way to get and expand
your mind and get into a situation that
you wouldn't before if you were more
privileged i disagree i think you can
put yourself in certain rooms i think
you can go to certain places there's
loads of events every single week social
media social media and i think social
media really allowed that to reach out
to whoever you want and i think um in
this day and age
learning is so free and i think you can
just meet whoever you want i think
there's a really i don't agree with that
i think it's great i think there's more
opportunities but the reality is
contacts are hugely important in order
to get on agree you know hugely
important you've had a little bit of a
get up clearly your parents know what
they're doing the fact that they haven't
actually had everything i just i
actually haven't had to get up i i i yes
i went to a great school until 16 but i
haven't been given money no no you don't
need you've got great talent clearly i'm
talking about the general
population if you like and we've got to
take get society to have a bit of a say
in what society needs out of our
education system if we just take nurses
as an example i'm sick of hearing how
many nurses we need yeah why are we
charging nurses to go to uni to get a
degree
surely something can be done don't tell
me about outside dentists we train for
10 years on the national health service
and they go private but that's very
honestly but let's just sort it out they
say i'll tell you what we'll pay you
we'll make you a bloody good nurse
excuse me you know but you're gonna have
to work for the nhs for a certain number
of years you also talk to business about
what do you want from our kids in school
you also talk about how uni is actually
there's very little face-to-face time
now my daughter was telling me i'm not
going to where she's going there'll only
be two terms in about 24 weeks what are
you doing for the rest of the year jim
well i think also the other challenge as
well is that a lot of people are going
to come out with let's say 27 000 pounds
worth of debt 37. yep
exactly and that's a big decision to
make when you're 16 to 18 years old but
then you see that one of the girls on
the producers who works on the show said
to me it was the best debt i ever took
she said you don't start paying it back
until you get to a certain level did you
know that if you start you can't pay it
just gets wiped off if you go out the
country for four years who picks up that
bill but then do we get back surge to
the argument that which will go down
like a lead balloon there are too many
colleges and too many bla i'm always
colored by the fact that i i found out
years ago that you can go to the
university of keele and you can do a
degree in business and marketing and you
can major in brand beckham
what the hell does that do exactly and
that undermines the whole education
system as far as i'm concerned the
university is getting nine grand a year
the average that a head teacher will get
per pupils five and a half we give them
36 weeks my teachers work after school
saturday mornings to make sure the kids
get the exam what are they doing for
nine grand because there is no face to
face pupil teacher ratios are huge it's
all online my kids have been to uni i
know what it goes so i think it's a time
maybe to have a look if we ever get an
education secretary here long enough to
actually look at things let's have a
look at what society needs from our
education system get every employer we
can what do you want for our kids let's
start off with you know what we want
them in on time every day
we want them to look appropriate we want
to be there we want a good attitude
that's never measured by anybody as an
employer i personally don't look at
someone i don't look at their education
and also don't look at their degree
which is great to hear but the the norm
i'm afraid is i did a a cross section
upstairs 90 of the people in the
production office have a degree i'm
interested in this apprentice sorry go
on i look at i think apprenticeships i
like apprenticeships i think that's
brilliant what you said just expand on
that a bit
experience being paid for it no debt and
probably if you prove yourself you've
got the job at the end of it absolutely
and i think that is very pragmatic but i
think therefore it's two ways it's not
just about people trying to pick useful
degrees but it's also about employers um
embracing and giving people
opportunities because also for an
employer's perspective you get to train
somebody up you get to train them in
your way and you can spend three years
training your way up to the position
that again there are lots of companies
out there that they won't even look at
people unless you have a graduate degree
so my alice today gets the results what
tips for her and the other students who
have decided today that they're going to
go what would you say okay obviously
financially it's going to be really
tough so here are my tips first of all
look at student discounts the national
union of students they say that they can
offer people if you go to and use all
their discounts they can save people
over 600 pounds a year and all the
discounts it's the clothes it's for uh
it's for food it's for rail travel if
there were any trains yeah that one yeah
and a rail travel as well you get a
third off of off peak travel as well i'm
also using go for secondhand books as
well for your course um if it's
obviously still applicable budgeting
apps also there are some bank accounts
that will allow you to open up in your
bank account and actually give you free
money um as well as discounts on council
tax as well so you take advantage of
student discounts while you can um
you're saying you can do it search very
quickly you'll see
don't be pigeonholed it doesn't have to
be very quickly also very quickly i just
want to say about these apprentices
ironically the way the area where
apprenticeships are growing are for top
10 kids
all right those kids are going to be all
right anyway i'm sorry you're going to
get the best the businesses are looking
around these top companies they're
looking for a star kids
we need another option for kids who are
great got great talent and willing to
work which is which is what this man is
saying thank you to serge to gemma and
of course to sam
that's it then another week of me
covering from the big man that
apparently is the truth i could get used
to this we're back monday eight o'clock
at your place and just remember before
then keep it uncensored
[Music]
biggest issue in britain right now
undoubtedly is cost of living it is
energy and all that goes with that
inflation look you know i don't want the
government to do very much step back
from most of our lives but you know
there's a point when you say actually
these guys are getting a grip somewhere
along the line you want
to believe that the system that is meant
to be running things the chancellor the
prime minister who are going to somehow
step in and make life just a little
easier for the average person
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor a member
of the so-called islamic state beatles
has been sentenced to life in a u.s
prison al-shafi al-shaikh who's from the
uk was part of the group who filmed
themselves beheading western captives in
iraq and syria including british
volunteers david haynes and alan henning
presidents putin and macron have agreed
on the need for inspectors from the
international atomic energy agency to
visit the zaparizia nuclear power plant
the world nuclear watchdog has said
fighting around the site in ukraine is
very alarming and most london
underground lines have been down today
as underground workers walk out members
of the rmt union are striking over pay
and working conditions more strikes will
take place tomorrow on the rail network
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you